Hello, I'm Charlie Goldstraw and I work in the Enterprise team at Portswigger.
Over the last two months, we've been working on improving the load speeds for customers with larger web estates in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
In this video, I'm going to share three key performance improvements that we've made.
And to put each performance improvement in context, I'm going to play the loading times before our fixes on a large enterprise environment.
Then attempt to explain each improvement faster than the site's loading time.
The first change we've made is to our bulk selection feature, which you can use to perform bulk actions on sites.
The problem with bulk selection was that for each selected site, the front end would perform a search of the whole site tree to find site details,
making it scale quadratically with respect to the number of sites.
This was solved by reordering the logic to remove this linear search, taking bulk selection down on 5,000 sites from 22 seconds,
to just 1.5 seconds.
One of the most serious performance problems occurred with our second change, the site details page.
It was discovered that the site details page loading would slow down significantly when the site had lots of data,
especially with API sites with hundreds of endpoints.
The problem in this instance was that the site details page shows a variety of different information, including request headers, endpoints, and authentications,
which were all gathered using a single query.
However, in order to gather this varied information, the SQL would use a series of table joins across the relevant tables,
which multiplies the number of return rows for each data type.
This means that if you had two endpoints and added just two more, you would double the amount of data processed in the query.
By splitting each data type into its own query, a complex site like this one speeds up from 109 seconds to just 1.4 seconds.
Site details were also queried in a number of other places, meaning this fix will improve many other areas of the site.
Lastly, we've also made improvements to the dashboard.
The dashboard is my favorite performance improvement because the main reason that it took 30 seconds to load for larger states
was that it simply had so much processing to do, showing a variety of up-to-date personalized graphs
based on the information that you have permission to view.
However, by moving the majority of the processing to the backend and giving the smallest possible amount of work to JavaScript,
we improved the dashboard loading from 30 seconds to just 1.5 seconds.
Burp Suite Enterprise Edition version 2024.11 will feel more responsive to the demands of large web estates.
In just these areas, for this size of installation, the total loading times have decreased from 200 seconds to 6 seconds.
On faster hardware, the cumulative load times decrease again to just 1.2 seconds.
These performance updates are amongst a number of improvements and features we've introduced in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition this winter.
Click the link in the description to find out more.
Click the link in the description below.
Click the link below.